This episode is gifted with limited commercial interruption by Macy's. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hi lady.
Hi there. Hi, everyone. Welcome to a little Friday chit-chat. You guys, I'm really excited because we're talking about moms. Yeah, this is our special early Mother's Day bonus episode. We're going to share about our own moms. We're going to share about ourselves. And we're going to share about your moms because you wrote us all about your moms.
And it was pretty awesome. And we thought a special way to kick things off would be to hear from our moms. I don't know what Jenna's mom sent in. and Jenna doesn't know what my mom sent in. But we did two different questions for them. Yeah, I asked my mom, what do you love about being a mom? Because lady, I love being a mom. I just love it. And I know you do too. It's one of the ways that we connect through our love of parenting. And I wanted to hear, what does my mom like about it? Or what did she like about it when we were little or anything? That was my prompt. So here's what she had to say. Happy Mother's Day, everyone. This is Jenna's mom, and I'd like to share with you some of my fond memories of being a mother when my two girls were at home and they were little ones. First of all, I was so excited to have a girl the first time.
Oh, my gosh, I was just beyond happy. And the second time, I was even happier than that. if that could be so, but I really was. One of my favorite things to do was to watch them sleep at night, especially as babies when they would curl their little feet under their little behind. I always thought that was so cute, and I just love seeing that. We used to like to roughhouse as a family in the family room with the dog. That was always so much fun, and that was usually after dinner when we would do that type of family entertainment, if you can call that entertainment.
And I was always so proud, even to this day, to watch them perform. As children, they dance, both Jenna and Emily. They were both pretty good dancers, by the way. and I always felt so proud sitting in that audience, watching them up there on that stage. And of course, even today, watching Jenna on TV or Jenna in the movies, I still have those same feelings. And probably the thing that touched my heart the most was when they would bring me little gifts. And when they were young, they would bring me dandelions, you know, think, that they were flowers. Of course, I always put them in a little vase, even though there wasn't any
real odor to them. I'd put them by the sink and they would make me smile every time I would look at them. So anyway, those are a few of my Mother's Day fondest memories and I hope you think of your fondest memories too today. Happy Mother's Day again. Bye now. That is so sweet. my heart lady, and I got to see a little window into my best friend's childhood through the eyes of her mom. Oh, I loved that. It's funny that she mentioned the rough housing in the family room because with the dog, because I have such memories of that. And they were this really joyous time in the evenings. And we had one of those kind of sunken living rooms, you know, where you had to step down into it with the green shag carpet.
Oh my gosh. The wood paneled walls. And yeah, my mom would put on a record, usually like Barry Manilow was her favorite. And she would sing. And then we would wrestle my dad, but we'd wrestle. The dog would get in there. And we would just kind of sing and wrestle. And my little sister was like such a daredevil.
She wanted to do the airplane game, you know, where. Oh, yeah. My dad would lay on his back and he would put her up in the air like an airplane. And she'd be flipping around and we would joke like when we would wrestle. She would throw her whole body into it. He'd be like, oh, geez, Emily, come on. So all those memories came flooding back in. I loved having my mom answer that question.
It's something that I'd never asked her really before, you know? Yeah. It's just so special. I mean, our moms, of course, they're just like whole fully realized people. And you think as a kid, you know everything about your mom. But there's so many treasures still to learn, right? Well, lady, what did you ask your mom? Okay. So I asked my mom, what was something your mom did that inspired you that you then carried on when you became a mom. And, you know, my grandmother's name was Viola May. And I was really curious. to hear what my mom would say because I know my mom misses her so much. So shout out to my sister Janet, who helped record this with my mom. And here's what she had to say. I think one of the most amazing things my mom did to inspire me and teach me is every school year, she would get the catalog down, probably Sears and Rosebuck, Rosebuck or whatever that is.
And she would tell me, pick out what you want, skirts, shirts. We didn't wear pants to school. And I would pick out the prettiest patterns. I mean, I'd just go there and I'd see a picture and I'd pick it out. And then I'd, and she would make me the exact copy of what I picked out. And she, every year, and if I needed anything else during the year, she would tell my sister best best would get the fabric
and mom would make it like in home at you know we had to make things back then but my mom every year she would cut she would sew for me my whole school wardrobe and I was one of the best dressed kids in school
that's the amazing thing and it probably sparked the same thing in me because I made everything for you girls until blue jeans come in then I quit sewing for you mostly but Billy and Janet you know they'd come in from school
when they were in high school or even going to church camp they'd have to have like two outfits a day and I'd make those sometimes staying up at 1 or 2 o'clock in the morning and then Billy come home like they were going to have something in high school. And she said, Mom, I really need this like tomorrow night. So I don't know.
I'd figure out a way to make it. And that's my mom. That's what she has. She inspired me. That's just one of the ways, though. I love her to pieces. Is that what you expected her to say? No, I had no idea, you know.
I really didn't. My mom comes from a really big family and they would all pitch in and help. But I had no idea what she was going to say specifically about her mom. But I loved it. I did not know the catalog story that they would get the Sears catalog and flip through it. I'd never heard that before. So that was just like I got to spend a little moment with my mom and my grandmother. Oh, it was so special.
I loved hearing it. Well, lady, I want to share one other audio clip if it's okay. Yeah. So I knew that my mom wasn't going to be able to figure out how to record herself. So I got my dad on board. And, you know, he is a former engineer, so he took this assignment very seriously. And he sent me a test audio before he recorded my mom. Oh, my goodness.
lady, that is so sweet. And I have to share it. I asked him if I could because it's just kind of amazing. Okay, so this is a test to see how this works and to see if it can be sent when I finish.
Actually, I'm reading a text from Jenna. It's about flights. I'll take a look at that when I get done doing this, but this is 24 seconds at this point. We'll see what It's like for about 90 seconds and then I'll send it. So I got my grass cut today.
I'll do Emily's lawn tomorrow. I have her sending the kids out to pick up all the branches and twigs out of the yard because that just ruins the lawnmower blades. When I took the lawnmower in for service at the end of the summer last year, they did a complete overhaul and they said we were replaced. both of your blades because they were in such bad shape, we couldn't even sharpen them. So I'm hoping that they'll last for a while. That's it.
He made it to the time limit and he just stopped talking. I love it that like somewhere in the middle of that, he took a screen grab photo, probably of the text message I had sent him about flights because I'm going home soon to see my nephew in his school musical. and then my mom and I are going to go do a mother's stay trip to New York, actually. And the whole thing was just sort of amazing to me. And I loved it. It's just so adorable. My mom and sister couldn't figure out the voice memo.
So what my sister did was she just filmed my mom answering. Yeah, like a video. Except she just filmed the tablecloth. So you don't even see my mom. That was really special. and I'm so thankful to have both of those stories from your mom and my mom. Well, listen, the next thing we decided to do was we wanted to share three things that we love about our moms that we have carried into our own lives.
So, lady, do you want to start and then we can go back and forth? Yeah, yeah, that's perfect. Well, my first thought when I thought of my mom was how she has always just sports. positive words and prayers over me and my sisters. She always builds us up. She really taught me that our words are so powerful and that when we speak over ourselves and the people we love, that can really take root in a person. And to this day, you will not hear my mom say anything negative about anything in her life or our lives. And when I was a kid, it would sometimes annoy me because, you know, I'd be frustrated and I just would want to be annoyed about something
and vent. And sometimes I would get down on myself or I'd want to give up. And she just flat out would not let me, you know? She would let me kind of have the moment to blow off the steam, but then she'd be like, all right, now that's done and you're going to tackle this and it's going to be okay. But she really just always kept building us up. And there is a scripture that she would say to me that I carry with me always. I'm going to probably paraphrase it and not get it exactly right for those listening, but you'll know it. It's out of the abundance of the heart, the mouth speaks.
And when I think about that, when I get down sometimes and I'm griping or I'm just kind of like being negative, I pause and I say, wait, what is my heart full of? Because I don't want my heart to be full of negative things. So, yeah, I think about that a lot. My mom just has always built me and my sisters up. She is someone that just speaks positive over the people in her life. That's powerful. It's really powerful.
Will you say the quote again, Angela, the scripture? Out of the abundance of the heart, the mouth speaks. I love that. Isn't that great? And it's such a thing that. I hold, even when I meet people, and some people, you know, you'll see them kind of just spew out some stuff. And I think, I'm going to pray for their heart. Because they're holding on to a lot of negativity. And it's coming out. Well, you definitely bring that into your life,
lady. You do. I try to. I really do. You do. I did not know we had your mom to think for that. But I get a lot, I'm the receiver of a lot of that. So I'm very grateful to your mom. Well, thanks, lady. And thank you, Bertie. What about you? What was the first thing you thought of? Well, the first thing that came to my mind was my mom's love of travel. That my mom loves travel. She loves learning. She loves seeing new places, experiencing new cultures and people. And when we were growing up, she would always find ways for us to travel and explore. She would research things that were happening in neighboring states around Missouri. And we would just load up in the station wagon.
And like one year we went to Graceland. And we just immersed in Elvis and his music and we went to Graceland. And then I also remember driving one time to Memphis to see. this traveling King Tut exhibit at a museum. And she was always planning this stuff, dreaming it up. What are things we could see? What are experiences she could give us? And along with my dad, she's been to so many places in the world. They're still traveling. My mom's in her late 70s. My dad is almost 80, and they're going to go to Iceland later this year. That is amazing. Yeah, and I just know that her list is never ending.
She will always want to explore and see things, but I definitely carry that with me, and I 100% credit her with that. You really do, and you're also someone like you want to learn, you know, and that's a big part of your mom wanting to see all these places. She wants to learn, like, how do people live here? What's important to them? You know, what are the adventures?
How do they get out? into nature, like the food. Like, she's a very curious person in that way, and I think that is wonderful. Well, my mom always said to us that she thinks it's important to see how other people live. Whatever that means. You know, she's said before, San Francisco is so different from New Orleans. You know, it's like Texas is so different from Montana. She's like, you should try to see places that are different from,
what you're used to because it opens you up. It opens you up to people. And that was always really important to her. And so she definitely instilled that in me. And she's such a talker and people person that she is going to want to meet the locals. She's never met a stranger. Correct. Correct. Yeah. Well, I just love that. All right. Are you ready for my second one? Yes. Okay. So my mom, who will be 88 this year, lady. And she is still just out there, just doing her thing. And so when I think of her, the other thing I really think of is she is a do-it-yourselfer kind of person. And I had written this, you know, what I was going to share, before I listened to her audio clip, right, before I got the video that they sent.
So guess what she was doing when she made that video? Was she quilting? She was sewing me a cushion cover for my little fireplace bench. Oh, amazing. So it is so much a part of her and clearly so much a part of her mom because she talked about that so lovingly. And, you know, my mom grew up in a very big farming family and they often had a tough time making ends meet. But my mom said she never felt like they lacked for anything because they always figured out a way to you know, make the things they needed. And I just can't tell you how many times I have seen my mom
tackle a big project by herself. I mean, she sews, she quilts. You know, you'll be like, oh, I wish I had a tote bag. She's made you one. Oh, a crossover purse. She made you one. I saw these when Isabel was little. It looked like a little purse, but it was a dollhouse. And then the roof opened and the little dolls were inside, but it looked like a little handbag. My mom made that for Isabel. I mean, what? Table runners, Christmas trees. You know, Jenna.
tackle a big project by herself. I mean, she sews, she quilts. You'll be like, oh, I wish I had a tote bag. She's made you one. Oh, a crossover purse. She made you one. I saw these when Isabel was little. It looked like a little purse, but it was a dollhouse. And then the roof opened and the little dolls were inside, but it looked like a little handbag. My mom made that for Isabel. I mean, what? Table runners, Christmas trees. You know, Jenna.
It goes on and on. And I just love that about her. And I really feel like I've carried that into my life, too. I think that I never approach a project with, well, we can't do that. I'm always like, all right, all right, let's see. Let's see if we can figure it out. And one of my favorite examples is that my mom came to visit me years ago. And like before I was a mom, I was just sort of setting up my first little house.
And the backyard did not have a walkway from the back door to the grass. I knew exactly what you were about to say because I have this memory of you because this was early in our friendship. And I remember thinking, season two of the office. Yes, I remember thinking this is my person. So anyway, this little house had a back door, and then it was just dirt, and it was dirt for a little bit until you got to the grass. And I was like, gosh, I wish I had a path from the back door to the yard, you know? And my mom was like, all right, let's do it. And I was like, what do you mean?
We went to the hardware store. We bought a pallet of grass. We bought bricks and cement. And that day we laid a palette of grass and we mixed the cement in a bucket and we made a brick path from the back door to the yard. I remember this so vividly, you and your mom laying down this path in your backyard. I was like, I love these ladies. But yeah, I love that about her. All right.
What's your number two? My number two goes a little bit with my number one. but my mom is a get your hair wet in the ocean kind of mom. Oh, yes. So I love that. She's not afraid to get herself messed up. No. And that would be true when she's cooking.
She makes a big old mess all over the kitchen. You know, she'll get muddy while she's gardening. And if she's at an ocean, she's going to just get in, you know? Mm-hmm. And I just, I love that about her. She's not fussy or vain. And it was inspiring to me. You know, I loved that my mom will just get her hair wet in the ocean with me.
When I was little, and to this day, she's still that kind of mom. She's just going to jump right off the back of the boat into the water. I love it. Yeah. And that is so real. Like when you said that, I just knew immediately, like, I know those women and they're so inspiring. I love that your mom is like, I'm going to jump in the ocean. My hair is going to be matted, sticking to my forehead kind of gal.
All right. Here's my last number three. And of course, I mean, you guys, when Jenna and I were talking about this, we're like, three things. That's it. We could go on and on. But we try to limit it to three because we really also want to hear from you guys and you wrote in the most lovely tributes.
So here's my number three. My mom is the person who inspired me to never stop being here. curious. You know, I've always sort of shared here that I don't think you age out of wanting to learn new things. And that is so true. My mom was in her late 30s when she decided she was going to learn tennis. And there she was a brand new tennis player and she ended up winning the singles tournament like a year later in our neighborhood. Our neighborhood had like tennis courts where you could like enter tournaments. And mom won it. And all those other women have been playing for a long time.
She also decided that she was going to learn how to paint. And she's an amazing artist. I have her paintings hanging in my house. Yeah. So those are just very small ways to show you guys that she is a curious person and she loves to learn. And there is no age limit to that. And she's still learning new things.
I mean, I can't tell you how deep on Pinterest my mom has gone. She loves like YouTube tutorials on how to make things. So I just love that. She's almost 88 and still wanting to learn new things. That's awesome. And you're like that too, lady. I love that. This is just making me so happy this episode.
我是说，我无法形容我妈妈在Pinterest上有多沉迷。她喜欢看各种关于怎么做手工的YouTube教程。所以我真的很喜欢这一点。她快88岁了，却依然想学新东西。这太棒了。你也是这样的人，女士。我太喜欢了。这一集让我觉得太幸福了。
What is your number three? So my number three is that my mom is the person who gave me the courage to pursue a career in acting. Yeah. And I'm going to get a little emotional, but even though we lived in the middle of the country very far away from Hollywood, and even though we didn't know anyone in the entertainment industry, from a very early age, when I expressed interest in wanting to have a career as an actor, she took me seriously. And she never treated it like a dream or like a fantasy. She treated it like something I could achieve. She never said, she never said it. said, oh, that's silly. Instead, she said that she felt a calling in life to be a teacher, and she loved her job. And she said, if you feel called to be an actor, then that is what you should try to do. And I know that kind of belief in me from such a young age was a big boost to my ability to succeed in this business, because I never had to justify my choice. I never had to push back against an unsupportive family.
你的第三点是什么？我的第三点是，我妈妈给了我追求演艺事业的勇气。是的。我要有点情绪激动了，尽管我们住在国家的中部，离好莱坞非常远，而且尽管我们在娱乐行业没有任何人脉，但从小时候起，当我表达出想成为一名演员的兴趣时，她就非常认真地对待我。她从未把它当作一个梦想或幻想。她把它当作一件我可以实现的事情。她从没说过，她从没说过那很傻。相反，她说她觉得人生中有一种呼唤要去当一名老师，她热爱她的工作。她说，如果你觉得有呼唤要去当演员，那这就是你应该去尝试的事情。我知道从那么小的时候起，这种对我的信念极大地增强了我在这一行成功的信心，因为我从来不需要为自己的选择辩解。我从来不需要去抵制一个不支持我的家庭。
One of my friends that I moved to Los Angeles with, her family were constantly fighting with her, telling her she should come home, telling her she should lead a more traditional life. She was so conflicted, she was depressed. It was so much work for her to be self-expressed. Like if she didn't book a job, her family would say, well, I guess you should come home.
我和我一起搬到洛杉矶的一个朋友，她的家人经常和她吵架，告诉她应该回家，告诉她应该过更传统的生活。她内心非常挣扎，甚至得了抑郁症。为了做自己，她付出了巨大的努力。比如说如果她没有接到工作，她的家人就会说，好吧，我想你应该回家了。
But if I didn't book a job, my mom would say, you'll get the next one. Just hang in there. Just hang in there. You can do it. And it created a strength in me that I'm so grateful for. And I realize how lucky I am to have a mom, a parent, who listened and accepted me for who I was and didn't try to change me. Wow, that is just, I think one of the most important gifts you can give your kid is just seeing them. And you do that with your kids, lady.
但如果我没有接到工作，我妈妈会说，你会拿到下一个的。坚持住。再坚持一下。你能做到的。这在我心中培养了一种力量，对此我非常感激。我也意识到自己有多么幸运，能有一位妈妈、一位家长，她能倾听并接受本来的我，而不是试图改变我。哇，这简直是，我认为你能给孩子最棒的礼物之一就是看见他们。你在对待自己的孩子时也是这样的，女士。
I've watched you many times when they tell you something, you take them at their word. You don't blow them off. Do you know what I mean? It's like, if it's important to them, it's important to you. And you don't scoff at them and be like, oh, well, no, you're like, okay, this is what you're interested in right now. We're going to learn everything we can about it. Yeah. Now listen, that's not to say that my mom saw every part of me or understood every part of me,
我多次看到，当他们对你说什么时，你是完全相信他们的。你不会把他们打发走。你知道我的意思吗？就像，如果这对他们很重要，对你来说也很重要。你不会嘲笑他们，而是会说，好吧，这就是你现在感兴趣的东西。我们要把关于它的所有事情都学透。是的。现在听着，这并不是说我妈妈看到了我所有的部分，或者理解了我所有的部分，
but this was a way where she did just have an open heart and an encouragement that meant so much to me because this was a really big piece of me that if I had to suppress this my whole life, I think I would have been sad, like my friend was sad, you know? Yeah. So I appreciate that. I do too. I really do. I mean, my family was just kind of scratching their heads when I was like, you know, I want to go to California. And mom said I told them when I was four. I wanted to be Carol Burnett. So she knew it was coming. But it was tough, but they were supportive. But I mean, I think about it now with our kids lady, if I'm like, Isabel's looking at colleges. I'm like, you has to be driving distance for me. You can't go that far. Yeah. I mean, she always, my mom has always said, like, the one part about it that, you know, broke my heart was how far away you are to do this thing. I think she loves that my sister lives close. Yeah, I know. And I'm thankful for that, too. I'm thankful that our sisters are close by.
但通过这种方式，她确实有着一颗开放的心和鼓励的态度，这对意义重大，因为这是我非常重要的一部分如果我一辈子都要压抑这一点我想我会很难过就像我朋友难过的那样你知道吗？是的。所以对此我很感激。我也是。我真的是。我是说，当我跟家里说我想去加州时，他们简直一头雾水。妈妈说我四岁时就告诉过他们我想成为卡罗尔·伯内特。所以她知道这是迟早的事。但这很艰难，不过他们很支持。但我是说，现在想想我们的孩子们，女士，如果伊莎贝尔在看大学，我会说，你必须在我开车能到的距离内。你不能去那么远。是的。我是说，她总是，我妈妈总是说，唯一让我心碎的一点就是你离得那么远去做这件事。我想她很喜欢我姐姐住得近。是的，我知道。我也为此很感激。我很感激我们的姐姐们都在附近。
Yeah. Oh, moms, man, they're just, like, complex and layered and amazing. and I feel like my mom's an onion. Like there's always some layer. And I'm like, what? You did what? When was that? I didn't know that. Yeah.
是的。哦，妈妈们，天哪，她们真的是那种复杂、有层次又了不起的人，我觉得我妈妈就像一个洋葱。总是会有新的层次。然后我会想，什么？你做了什么？什么时候的事？我不知道那件事。是的。
And, you know, as we're talking about moms and stuff, I did, you know, just want to shout out the other women in my life who were also so nurturing and supportive, you know? I had teachers and coaches and neighbors. And I'm sure, Jenna, you did too. The list goes on and on. And I feel like in honor of those people that helped shape our lives. and we're such an important part of our lives that maybe we're never biological mothers.
而且，你知道，当我们谈论妈妈们之类的话题时，我确实，你知道，只是想向我生命中的其他女性致敬，她们也同样给予我滋养和支持，你知道的？我有老师、教练和邻居。我相信，珍娜，你也是。这样的名单长得数不清。我觉得为了纪念那些塑造了我们生活、并且是我们生活中如此重要的一部分的人，也许她们从来都不是生下我们的母亲。
I mean, we all mother someone in some way, you know? Yeah, Angela, you know, sometimes your mothering doesn't come from a biological mom. Yeah. It can come from lots of places. And so thank you to all those people, too. That's right. Well, lady, why don't we take a break? And then when we come back, we are going to hear from you.
我是说，我们都在某种程度上母爱般地照顾着某人，你知道吗？是的，安吉拉，你知道的，有时候你的这种母爱并非来自亲生母亲。是的。它可以来自很多地方。所以也谢谢所有这些人。没错。好吧，女士，我们为什么不休息一下呢？然后等我们回来，我们要听听大家的分享。
We're going to share some of your tributes and letters that you wrote us about your moms. This episode is gifted with limited commercial interruption by Macy's. Mother's Day is right around the corner. It is May 10th. It's coming up. You've got about two and a half weeks, everybody. And Macy's makes it easy to find a gift that feels thoughtful and spot on. They have fun, gifting inspo ideas.
我们将分享一些你们写给我们的关于你们妈妈的致敬信和信件。本期节目由梅西百货赞助播出，广告插播有限。母亲节就在眼前。就是5月10日。快到了。大家大概还有两周半的时间。梅西百货让寻找贴心又精准的礼物变得轻而易举。他们有有趣的送礼灵感创意。
and also can't miss deals. And you know, I love a deal. And you know, they've got something for all of the types of moms out there. We've got mom, mother-in-law, maybe your favorite dog mom, or any other maternal figure in your life that you'd like to celebrate this year. Macy's has great ideas. They've got their gift list. Lady, what are you thinking?
还有不容错过的优惠。你知道的，我喜欢优惠。你知道的，他们为各种类型的妈妈准备了合适的礼物。我们有妈妈、婆婆，也许你最喜欢的狗狗妈妈，或者你今年想要庆祝的任何其他母性角色。梅西百货有很多好主意。他们有他们的礼物清单。女士，你在想什么？
Can I tell you, by the way, Macy's has beautiful jewelry. That's what I was going to say. Beautiful. One year I bought myself a Mother's Day gift, and I bought myself these little emerald earrings. Lady. Well, you know what I think is making a comeback? And this is what I might ask for. Oh, what?
我可以告诉你，顺便说一句，梅西百货有漂亮的珠宝。我正想这么说。太漂亮了。有一年我自己买了一份母亲节礼物，我给自己买了这些小绿宝石耳环。女士。好吧，你知道我觉得什么正在卷土重来吗？这也是我可能会要求的。哦，什么？
Is it making a comeback, or am I making it make a comeback? I don't know. Pearls. Oh, they are making a comeback. And Macy's has them. They have cultured freshwater pearl bangle bracelets. And they have pearl drop earrings. to match. That sounds so, like, nice. I like it. I know. It's like elegant. I don't know. I'm into this
是它在卷土重来，还是我在引领它卷土重来？我不知道。珍珠。哦，它们正在卷土重来。梅西百货就有。他们有养殖淡水珍珠手镯。还有与之搭配的珍珠耳坠。听起来太棒了，太好了。我喜欢。我知道。这很优雅。我不知道。我很喜欢这种
look. Here's the thing, you guys, Macy's has every category you can imagine for the moms out there that you love and want to celebrate. They also have a whole lineup of gifts that are $50 and under. So go to Macy's. Check out Macy's online gift guide for more ideas and options under $50. And listen, if you've got spring events coming up, they've got some sales going on. So this is a good time to shop for yourself as well. And how about treat yourself to a session with a Macy's personal stylist who can help you get a new look for Mother's Day brunch, events, or whatever else you've got coming up. Book a session today and get 20% off your purchase with them. We are back and I'm going to kick us off with a beautiful letter from Zoe P in Dallas, Texas.
造型。事情是这样的，大家伙儿，梅西百货拥有你能想象到的每一个品类，送给你所爱并想要庆祝的妈妈们。他们还有一系列50美元及以下的礼物。所以去梅西百货看看吧。查看梅西百货的在线礼物指南，了解更多50美元以下的创意和选择。听着，如果你有春季活动要参加，他们正在搞促销。所以现在也是给自己购物的好时机。何不犒劳自己，预约一位梅西百货的私人造型师，帮你为母亲节早午餐、活动或任何即将到来的场合打造新造型呢？今天就预约，购物还可享8折优惠。我们回来了，我将以德克萨斯州达拉斯市佐伊·P的一封美丽信件来开启这一段。
Zoe says, My mom speaks for the trees, both literally and figuratively. She is a high school AP environmental science teacher whose passion for the environment inspires generations of students as well as myself. She is the reason why I chose to study environmental science in college and why to this day I continue to be an advocate for our planet. Not only is my mom a beekeeper, she also raises chickens, grows a variety of fruits and vegetables in her backyard and bakes her own bread, including amazing flavors such as chocolate
佐伊说，我妈妈为大自然发声，无论是字面意思还是象征意义。她是高中AP环境科学老师，她对环境的热情激励了一代又一代的学生以及我自己。这就是为什么我选择在大学里学习环境科学，也是为什么直到今天我依然继续成为我们星球的倡导者。我的妈妈不仅是一名养蜂人，她还养鸡，在后院种植各种水果和蔬菜，并自己烤面包，包括令人惊艳的口味，比如巧克力
cherry and cinnamon swirl. Her dedication to living sustainably and compassion towards all living beings is one of my favorite things about her. Given she is a teacher, my mom does not often get the recognition that she deserves, especially when teaching such a niche subject. So I wanted to take this moment to let the world know what an amazing person she is and how much she means to me. I cannot imagine a world without her, and neither can Mother Nature. I love that. I know. Aw.
樱桃和肉桂卷。她对可持续生活的热情以及对所有生命的热爱是我最喜欢她的地方。鉴于她是一名老师，我妈妈并没有经常得到她应得的认可，特别是当她教授这样一个冷门学科时。所以我想要借此机会让世界知道她是一个多么了不起的人，她对我的意义有多重大。我无法想象没有她的世界，大自然母亲也一样。我喜欢这个。我知道。啊。
All right. Well, I wanted to share from Leah S. in Germany, who said, Hey, guys, I know you want to talk about moms. I wanted to introduce you to my grandma. I hope that's okay. Leah, it's very much okay. Yes, it is. This is exactly what we were saying before the break, right?
好的。好吧，我想分享来自德国的莉亚·S的来信，她说，嘿，伙计们，我知道你们想谈论妈妈。我想向你们介绍我的奶奶。希望这可以。莉亚，完全可以。是的，当然可以。这正是我们在休息前所说的，对吧？
Sometimes mothers come. in other forms, like teachers and like grandmas. My grandmother is the coolest person I know. She's my idol in so many ways. She's teach me to view the world in a beautiful way. When I was little, she would be there in the morning because my mom would have to go to work very early. She would make me hot chocolate and I would lie in her arms. The headlights of the cars passing our streets reflected on the walls. Every reflection had a different story. a different person behind the wheel. She taught me to build tables and make fire.
有时候母亲会以其他形式出现，比如老师和奶奶。我的祖母是我认识的最酷的人。她在很多方面都是我的偶像。她教会我以一种美好的方式看待世界。在我小的时候，她会在早晨出现，因为我妈妈不得不很早去上班。她会给我做热巧克力，我会躺在她怀里。经过我们街道的汽车的车头灯倒映在墙上。每一个倒影都有一个不同的故事，方向盘后面都有一个不同的人。她教我做桌子和生火。
She showed me what plants I could eat and which ones would make me sick. She showed me how to cook marmalade. She didn't secretly give me money or chocolate like the other grandmas. She built a house and made sure I got into the right school. She was on the phone for hours when I wrongfully didn't pass an exam
她告诉我哪些植物可以吃，哪些会让我生病。她教我怎么做果酱。她不会像其他奶奶那样偷偷给我钱或巧克力。她盖了一座房子，并确保我能进入好的学校。当我不小心考试没通过、无法升入高一时，她打了几个小时的电话
and couldn't get into 11th grade. She forced me to visit her every second day to teach me math so that I could pass tests and exams in school. She went mushroom picking with me even when I was 14 and wanted to be anywhere but the goddamn woods. She made me listen to singing birds I can now differentiate. She bought me a new MacBook so I could edit my movie on it so I could get into film school. She directed movies that both broke and healed hearts. She could have been anyone. She could have had any career or job. I sometimes cry when I can't comprehend how much I love this woman. In fact, I'm crying right now. Today, she taught me how to renew a seat cushion on a
她强迫我每两天去看她一次，教我数学，这样我才能通过学校的测试和考试。她带我去采蘑菇，甚至在我14岁、只想去任何地方而不是该死的树林里的时候也是如此。她让我倾听鸟儿的歌唱，现在我能分辨它们了。她给我买了一台新MacBook，这样我就可以在上面剪辑我的电影，从而能考进电影学校。她导演的电影既让人心碎又让人治愈。她本可以成为任何人。她本可以从事任何职业或工作。有时我无法理解自己有多爱这个女人，甚至会哭出来。事实上，我现在就在哭。今天，她教我如何翻新一个
vintage chair she got me for my 22nd birthday. I also have the coolest and most wonderful mom ever, but today I wanted to tell you about my grandma. I love you guys so much, and I'm so incredibly grateful for this podcast. I learned so much from you. Thanks. Oh, Leah, my mom would love to hang with your grandma. They would make so many things together. I would love to hang with Leah's grandma. I know.
她送给我的22岁生日复古椅子。我也有过最酷、最棒的妈妈，但今天我想跟你聊聊我的奶奶。我太爱你们了，对这个播客感激不尽。我从你们身上学到了很多。谢谢。哦，莉亚，我妈妈一定很乐意和你的奶奶一起玩。她们会一起做好多事情。我很乐意和莉亚的奶奶一起玩。我知道。
Gosh, the gifts. I love the specificity of the gifts that have been passed down from this woman to another. So, so special. Well, next up, we actually have an audio clip. Abby R. from Fort Wayne, Indiana, sent us in her tribute. Hi office ladies. My name is Abby and I just want to shout out my mom, Mary. First of all, she is your biggest fan. Angela, just a side note, she thinks if you two met in real life, you would be best friends with which honestly, I agree because she loves her birds and she loves her wine.
天哪，这些礼物。我喜欢从这个女人传给另一个女人的那些具体而微的礼物。太特别了。好了，接下来，我们实际上有一段音频剪辑。来自印第安纳州韦恩堡的艾比·R给我们发来了她的致敬。嗨，办公室女士们。我叫艾比，我只想对我的妈妈玛丽表示感谢。首先，她是你们的头号粉丝。安吉拉，顺便说一句，她认为如果你们俩在现实生活中相遇，你们会成为最好的朋友，老实说我非常赞同，因为她喜欢鸟类，也喜欢红酒。
I just want to shout out my mom because she's the one person I call for literally everything example. I called her because I was making a chuck roast for the first time and I called her and I said, mom, what kind of meat do I buy when I'm buying a chuck roast? And she just waited and said, a chuck roast. And lo and behold, I looked down searching that a chuck roast exists. So yeah, but my mom is who I turned to for everything. I just want her to know how special she is this Mother's Day. One of the biggest things she did for me was, unfortunately, before I had my son. I had a miscarriage that I couldn't tell her I was pregnant because it was so early on. So I called her the next morning and she was at my house in about two hours just to be with me all day.
我只是想感谢我的妈妈，因为她是我遇到什么事都会打电话的人，举个例子。我给她打电话，因为我第一次做牛胸肉，我打电话说，妈妈，我买牛胸肉的时候应该买什么肉？她等了一下说，牛胸肉。果然，我低头一查，还真有牛胸肉这东西。所以，遇到什么事我都会找我妈妈。这个母亲节，我只是想让她知道她是多么特别。她为我做过最大的事情之一是，不幸的是，在我生儿子之前。我流过一次产，当时我甚至不能告诉她我怀孕了，因为时间太早了。所以第二天早上我给她打电话，她大概两个小时就到了我家，只为了整天陪着我。
As well as when I had my son, who I have now, Felix, the first two weeks, the first really whole year of his life, mom's understand was really hard for a new mom. And she stayed with us those first two whole weeks and I couldn't make it through without her. So mom, I love you. Just know the gift that you are and how selfless you are. And I hope you have the best mother's day ever. Bye. Thanks, Jenna and Angela. Aw, I know. So wonderful. All of them, it's just a, it's just a beautiful thing, really. And I know, like, her mom lives two hours away, but she was like in that car immediately on her way. Yeah, you know, it's the story she told about the Chuck roast, that really got me because, you know, I'm faced with the realization that I won't have my mom
以及当我生下我现在的儿子菲利克斯时，头两周，可以说他生命中的整整第一年，作为一个新手妈妈，妈妈理解那对一个新手妈妈来说真的很艰难。她陪了我们整整前两周，如果没有她我根本撑不下来。所以妈妈，我爱你。只要知道你是多么宝贵的礼物，你又是多么无私。我希望你度过最棒的母亲节。再见。谢谢你，珍娜和安吉拉。啊，我知道。太棒了。所有这些，这真是一件，这真是一件美妙的事情。我知道，虽然她妈妈住在两小时车程外，但她就像立刻上了车赶过来一样。是的，你知道的，她讲的关于牛胸肉的故事，真的触动了我，因为，你知道的，我不得不面对这样一个现实，那就是我不会永远拥有我的妈妈
and dad forever. I mean, I'm 52 and they're getting older. And those are the moments, you know, those are the things when I want to be able to call my mom and say, mom, do I melt the butter or just soften it for the snowball recipe. I can't remember. And she tells me the answer. You know? The things that just her brain has that they hold. And I just have this desire to know them all
和爸爸。我的意思是，我52岁了，他们正在变老。就是那些时刻，你知道的，当我想给妈妈打电话说，妈妈，做雪球饼干食谱的时候，我是把黄油融化还是只软化？我记不清了。然后她告诉我答案。你知道吗？那些东西，只有她的脑子里才有，他们牢牢记着。我只是有一种渴望，想要知道所有这些
and access them all before they're lost to me. Yeah. One of the things that I miss the most about my dad is just being able to pick up the phone and call them. Mm-hmm. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
并在它们离我而去之前全部了解它们。是的。我最怀念我爸爸的事情之一，就是能够拿起电话打给他。嗯哼。是的。是的。是的。
Well, our next letter is from Lacey C in Oklahoma. And Lacey says, Hi, I would love to share this story about my mom because she, in my opinion, deserves so much recognition and appreciation. I am now 20, but when I was 15 and a freshman in high school, I suffered depression for the first time. I didn't understand it or how I was feeling and started to see no point in life. One of the hardest things that I did was tell my mom about the thoughts I was having and the things that I was feeling.
好了，我们的下一封信来自俄克拉荷马州的莱西·C。莱西说，嗨，我很想分享这个关于我妈妈的故事，因为在我看来，她值得如此多的认可和感激。我现在20岁，但当我15岁上高一的时候，我第一次经历了抑郁症。我不理解它，也不理解我的感受，开始觉得生命毫无意义。我做过的最难的事情之一，就是把我的这些想法和感受告诉了我妈妈。
She never once asked me why I felt that way. She never once judged me. And she immediately did everything she could to help me and to get myself to see life in a more positive way. She never allowed anyone else to judge me or tell my story. She's been my biggest advocate. She also has always told me that it is my story to share when I feel strong. enough to. This is only a small part of that story, but I will always appreciate everything that my mom did for me during that time of my life, on top of everything else she has done for me and
她从未问过我为什么会有这种感觉。她从未评判过我。她立刻尽其所能地帮助我，让我以更积极的眼光看待生活。她从不允许任何人评判我或讲述我的故事。她一直是我最坚定的支持者。她也一直告诉我，当我感觉足够坚强时，这是属于我自己的故事，可以由我来分享。这只是那个故事的一小部分，但我将永远感激我妈妈在我人生那个阶段为我做的一切，除此之外，她还为我做了一切并
sacrificed for me. I would also like to use this time to give a message to anyone who may be struggling. It may not seem like it right now, but it can and will get better. Asking for help is not a sign of weakness, but one of strength and tremendous bravery. If you're looking for a sign, this is it. I am now studying clinical psychology and Office Ladies podcast plays every morning on my drives to class. I love you guys. Oh, Lacey, thank you so much for sharing that. Yeah, thank you. With all my heart, I know for certain that your message reached someone. today. That's right. It reached someone who needed to be reached. Who needed to hear it. Yes. Well,
为了我做出了牺牲。我还想利用这段时间给任何可能正在挣扎的人带去一条信息。现在可能看起来并非如此，但情况会而且一定会有所好转。寻求帮助并不是软弱的标志，而是坚强和巨大勇气的体现。如果你在寻找一个信号，这就是了。我现在正在攻读临床心理学，每天开车去上课的路上都会播放《办公室女士》播客。我爱你们。哦，莱西，非常感谢你分享这些。是的，谢谢你。发自内心地，我深信你的信息今天传达到了某个人心里。没错。它传达到了需要被触及的人心里。需要听到它的人。是的。那么，
our next letter is from Emma P in Cambridge, Ontario, Canada. Emma says, my mom is one of the smartest people I know. She has a master's degree in math, but what mattered most to me growing up wasn't her credentials. It was what she taught me. When I was in elementary school, she didn't rely on worksheets or wrote memorization. Instead, she built her own math games in Microsoft Excel so I could learn my multiplication and division tables. She made learning feel empowering, creative, and possible. But her lessons didn't stop with numbers. She made sure my sister and I knew how to cook, how to manage money, how to budget, and how to do our taxes. She didn't just want us to succeed. She wanted us to be independent, capable, and confident adults who could stand on our own.
我们的下一封信来自安大略省剑桥市的艾玛·P。艾玛说，我妈妈是我认识的最聪明的人之一。她拥有数学硕士学位，但对我成长过程中最重要的事情并不是她的资历。而是她教给我的东西。当我还在上小学时，她并不依赖工作表或死记硬背。相反，她在微软Excel中构建了自己的数学游戏，以便我可以学习乘法和除法表。她让学习变得充满赋权、创造力和可能。但她的教导并不止于数字。她确保我和我姐姐知道如何做烹饪、如何管理金钱、如何做预算以及如何报税。她不仅希望我们成功。她希望我们成为独立、有能力、有自信、能够靠自己站稳脚跟的成年人。
There were three questions she asked us constantly. It was a routine we had every time we got in the car. From the moment we could talk, she would ask, are you smart, are you strong, are you capable? And before we could even fully understand the questions, we would always say yes, yes, and yes. She built our confidence the same way she built our skills, consistently, intentionally, and with love.
她不断地问我们三个问题。这是我们每次上车时都有的常规流程。从我们会说话的那一刻起，她就会问：你聪明吗？你坚强吗？你有能力吗？在我们甚至还不能完全理解这些问题之前，我们总是会说：是的，是的，是的。她建立我们自信的方式就像她建立我们的技能一样，坚定不移、用心良苦、充满爱意。
Last year, my mom was diagnosed with Alzheimer's. As her memory begins to fail, I find myself holding on to my memories of her even more tightly. And when I look back, I realize that everything she taught me is still there. The confidence that I can do anything, the resilience to try again if I fail, and the belief that I can figure things out myself. Even during hard times, those lessons don't fade. Now, as a new mom myself, I think about those memories a lot. whenever I talk with her, which we do regularly, we often go down memory lane as I remind her of the stories and everything she instilled in me. I hope I can live up to her example. I hope I can
去年，我妈妈被诊断出患有阿尔茨海默症。随着她的记忆力开始衰退，我发现自己更加紧紧地抓住了关于她的记忆。当我回首往事时，我意识到她教给我的所有东西都还在那里。我有能力做任何事情的自信，如果失败了卷土重来的韧性，以及相信自己能把事情弄明白的信念。即使在艰难时期，这些教训也没有褪色。现在，作为一名新手妈妈，我经常想起那些回忆。每当我与她交谈时——我们经常这样做——我们经常会回顾过去，因为我提醒她那些故事以及她灌输给我的所有事情。我希望我能不辜负她的榜样。我希望我能
instill the same confidence in my own daughter. And even now, whenever I buckle her in her car seat, I ask her the same questions my mom asked me, are you smart? Are you strong? Are you capable? And because she can't speak yet, I answer for her. Yes, yes. And yes, oh my gosh, is Megan Tera. Yeah. Oh, my gosh. Yeah. Oh, Emma, thank you for sharing that.
在自己的女儿身上灌输同样的自信。即使现在，每当我把她扣在安全座椅上时，我都会问她我妈妈问过我的那些问题：你聪明吗？你坚强吗？你有能力吗？因为她还不会说话，我替她回答。是的，是的。还有，天哪，这是梅根·特拉。是的。哦，天哪。是的。哦，艾玛，谢谢你分享这些。
That is so powerful. What an amazing woman your mom is. And I love those three questions. Women are amazing. Yeah. And the traditions and the determination and the love that we pass. through one another and to one another is just really freaking cool. It is.
这太震撼了。你的妈妈是多么了不起的女性啊。我喜欢那三个问题。女性太棒了。是的。我们在彼此之间传递以及向彼此传递的传统、决心和爱，真的太酷了。确实如此。
Well, I thought we could end with this letter from Winnie in San Jose, California, because this is another part of motherhood and it made me laugh. Here's what Winnie said. Winnie said, I love the office. My mom, however, does not at all. Sorry, ladies. But this means that when she sits down to watch it with me, usually after a tough day, it means the world to me. It's making me get choked up.
好吧，我想我们可以用这封来自加利福尼亚州圣何塞的温妮的信来结束，因为这是母职的另一个部分，它让我笑了。温妮是这么说的。温妮说，我喜欢《办公室》。然而，我的妈妈一点也不喜欢。对不起，女士们对我来说这意味着当她坐下来陪我看这部剧时，通常是在经历了艰难的一天之后，这对我来说意义重大。这让我哽咽了。
When he says, I'll always be grateful for that. She's the best. P.S., I shouldn't say she doesn't like it at all because I have frequently heard her singing the Hey, Mr. Scott song from Scott's Tots over the past several years. But I loved this letter lady because, you know, that's the thing. That's the thing about parenting. You know, my son loves music. He loves Metallica. I can't tell you how many hours of Metallica I have listened to.
温妮说，我将永远为此感激。她是最好的。附言，我不应该说她一点也不喜欢，因为过去几年里，我经常听到她唱《斯科特 Tots》里的“嘿，斯科特”之歌。但我喜欢这封信，女士，因为，你知道的，就是这样。这就是为人父母的真谛。你知道，我儿子喜欢音乐。他喜欢金属乐队。我无法告诉你我听了多少个小时的金属乐队。
It is not my cup of tea. I know it's not. And I know it so well. Yeah. He did get me into race. Age against the machine, I love them. I'm sorry, Metallica. I don't understand you musically. But that's the thing, you know, when you have a kid and they love something, you're going to love it with them, you know, whether you love it or not. It is. It's so true. It's the things we do. You know, we were just talking, Jenna, just the other day that, you know, sometimes we get up extra early and help our daughters with their hair. They're older now, so of course they can brush their hair. But if they want a fancy hairdo or something. And sometimes we're like doing things like that and we're like, we haven't even had our cup of coffee yet. We're trying to do some intricate hair. But I'm, I just know that I will miss all of it. You know, I'm,
这不是我的菜。我知道它不是。而且我很清楚这一点。是的。他确实让我迷上了雷吉，抗争机器乐队，我喜欢他们。对不起，金属乐队。我在音乐上无法理解你们。但这就是事情的本质，你知道，当你有了孩子，而他们喜欢某些东西时，你会和他们一起去爱它，无论你是否喜欢它。是的。这是真的。这就是我们做的事。你知道的，珍娜，我们不久前才谈到，你知道，有时我们会起得特别早，帮女儿弄头发。她们现在长大了，所以她们当然可以自己梳头。但如果她们想要一个华丽的发型什么的。有时我们在做那样的事情，然后我们就会想，我们甚至还没喝过一杯咖啡。我们正在努力做一个复杂的发型。但我，我只是知道我会想念这一切的。你知道，我，
I am looking at that empty nest. It is on the horizon for me for two of my kids. And then we'll have one at home. And Josh and I kind of joke that one is going to get so much attention. He's going to be like, back off. But what a joy it is to share these stories and to hear your stories. And so many people wrote in. And Jenna and I read all of them. Just so you know, we read every single one. And we would have loved to share every single one. They were all wonderful. So thank you so much. for sharing your tributes about your moms and grandmas. Yes. And thank you, everyone. We hope you have a great Mother's Day in a couple of weeks. And thank you, Macy's, for sponsoring this bonus episode. I know. It was a real joy.
我正在看着那个空巢。它对我的两个孩子来说已经在海平线上出现了。然后我们将有一个在家。乔希和我开玩笑说，那个孩子将会得到太多的关注。他会觉得：离我远点。但分享这些故事并听到你们的故事是多么快乐的一件事。有那么多人写信来。珍娜和我阅读了所有这些信件。为了让你们知道，我们阅读了每一封。并且我们本希望能分享每一封。它们都很棒。所以非常感谢你们分享关于你们的妈妈和奶奶的致敬。是的。谢谢大家。我们希望你们在几周后度过一个愉快的母亲节。谢谢梅西百货赞助这期特别节目。我知道。这真是令人高兴。
All right, everyone. We'll see you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle, and our audio engineer is Sam Keefer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz.
好了，各位。我们下周见。到时见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是奥德赛（Audyssey）的一个栏目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的高级制作人是马特·比格尔，我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。奥德赛执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带制作。
Our theme song is Ruppertry by Creed Bratton. Mother's Day might not be on your radar just yet, but y'all, it sneaks up fast before you know it is going to be here. It's true. If she's into beauty, you can't go wrong. They carry all the brands that she probably already knows and loves, like Valentino, Y, YSL, LaMere, Burberry, Prada, Shoshado, Clarence. I mean, there's no guesswork. And if she's more into timeless pieces, Macy's has gorgeous jewelry she can wear every day. I mean, really, they have every
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Ruppertry》。母亲节可能还不在你的雷达上，但各位，它来得飞快，转眼间就要到了。确实如此。如果她喜欢美妆，你绝对不会出错。他们拥有她可能已经了解并喜爱的所有品牌，比如华伦天奴、YSL、海蓝之谜、博柏利、普拉达、资生堂、娇韵诗。我的意思是，不需要瞎猜。如果她更喜欢永恒经典的单品，梅西百货有华丽的珠宝，她每天都可以佩戴。我的意思是，真的，他们拥有每一
type of jewelry. They have fancy diamond tennis bracelets. They have statement rings. They have those classic pendant necklaces. And for the mom who loves hosting, because I love to host, There's all kinds of gifts. They have beautiful tableware from brands like McKinsey Childs and like Crosette. So whether you've got a super specific gift in mind or you have no idea where to start, Macy's really helps you nail it. Check out Macy's online gift guide for more ideas. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
种类型的珠宝。他们有精致的钻石网球手链。他们有宣言戒指。他们有那些经典的吊坠项链。对于喜欢招待客人的妈妈来说——因为我喜欢招待客人——这里有各种各样的礼物。他们有来自麦肯齐-查尔斯和酷彩等品牌的精美餐具。所以，无论你心中有一个超级具体的礼物，还是根本不知道从哪里开始，梅西百货都能真正帮你搞定。查看梅西百货的在线礼品指南以获取更多创意。本集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。